SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH --
FIRST LET'S GO AHEAD ESTABLISH A
QUORUM THEN I'LL HAVE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE SO SIX
THREE CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CAN HEAR PAN HERE STONE.
STONE HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HERE GROW HER TADO.
TADO HERE LEYVA LEYVA HERE
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
HEY WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM
AND I THINK ALL THE MEMBERS --
WHO CAME DOWN -- TO QUORUM I'VE
SHOULD I JUST WANNA MAKE NOTE
THAT THAT WE HAVE MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD THAT I KNOW THAT MANY OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
SERVE ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
INCLUDING EVEN THE BUDGET.
SO -- YOU'LL SEE PEOPLE COMING
IN AND OUT AND JUST TO MAKE.
IT'S POSSIBLE FOR EXAMPLE THAT
ARE BUDGET CHAIR -- DEPENDING ON
HOW THE BUDGET HEARING GOES MARY
NOT MAY OR MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
MAKE IT DOWN THE FOR HEALTH
COMMITTEE SO I JUST THE BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT SHE'S NOT
SUPPORT OF THE MANY TO BILLS
THERE BEFORE US -- I WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS SO
FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE SIXTEEN
ITEMS OUR AGENDA TODAY -- WE ARE
NOT HEARING TWO ITEMS HAVE BEEN
HELD THAT'S ITEM NUMBER -- ONE
EIGHTY THIRTY FIVE BY SUMMER
KALRA IN ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY BY SUMMER TANG SO
WE WILL BE HOLDING THOSE OVER
THOSE ARE BEING -- WILL BE HEARD
TODAY WE ALSO HAVE FIVE ITEMS
UNDER CONSENT CALENDAR -- ITEM
NUMBER TWO IF YOU FORTY THREE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN SIXTY NINE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN AB.
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AND ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE I ALSO WANT --
TO WELCOME AT CENTER LEANING
GONZALEZ WELCOME -- TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO YOUR PARTICIPATION --
I WILL -- ALSO WANT TO THINK A
CERTAIN GARAGE SO WHO -- WHO --
FOR HER SERVICE ON THE COMMITTEE
AND I REALLY APPRECIATED HER
INPUT.
ON THE COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
SHE'S -- GETTING SHE HAS PLENTY
OF COMMITTEES TO BE BUSY ON SO --
BUT I WILL MISS HER HAVING HER
HERE -- IT AS I MENTIONED --
THAT CENTER MITCHELL IS CHAIRING
BUDGET WHICH IS BEING HELD
SIMULTANEOUSLY -- AND THEN ALSO
CENTER RUBIO IS CHERRY INSURANCE.
YEAH A TEACHER AND SO SHE SO YOU
MAY SEE SOME OF THE THESE THAT
THEIR SIMULTANEOUSLY CHAIRING
COMMITTEES SO THEY MAY BE LATE
AS WELL -- SO GENERAL RULES --
AS AS MOST OF YOU MAY KNOW -- IS-THAT -- WILL TAKE SIX MINUTES OF
PRO KINDS AND AGAIN YOU CAN DO
LESSEN SIX OF SUPPORTIVE
TESTIMONY AT SIX MINUTES OF
OPPOSITION.
AND THEN WILL TAKE THE ALSO THE
ADDITIONAL EXPRESSIONS OF
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WITH NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION OKAY
SO WITH THAT LET'S SEE WHO WE
HAVE HERE I SEE.
US ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA HERE
INTO THE SERVER WE ARE GOING
VOTER SELF WELCOME -- ITEM
NUMBER TWO IS ON CONSENT -- SO I
THINK YOU HAVE TWO OTHER ITEMS
YOU WANNA TAKE THEM AND FOLLOW
ORDER CERTAIN OKAY SO WE'LL.
MOVE ON SO -- WILL MOVE OUT SO
ITEM NUMBER -- FOUR EIGHTY TWO
SIXTY TWO LOCAL HEALTH OFFICE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I'LL BE A BRIEF SAID YOU HAVE TO
WIN THIS IS -- THIS BILL IS THE
RESULT.
OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HEPATITIS A OUTBREAK TO STARTED
SANDY SEE TO MAKES CLEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITIES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS.
TO THE PUBLIC AGAINST FUTURE
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE OUTBREAKS
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL CLARIFY
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS AUTHORITY
TO ISSUE HEALTH PORTERS AT A
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS I AM
REQUIRES LOCAL HEALTH OFFICER TO
MAKE RELEVANT INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE AVAILABLE TO THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
WITH ME TODAY JONATHAN CLAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND WEBER
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY CITY.
I THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
JONATHAN CLAIM TO HAVE THE
COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN KEEPING WITH
THE THE BREVITY AYE WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE HERE AS A SPONSOR
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORY ON
THIS AND FOR A MEASURE.
AS THIS FAMILY MEMBER IDENTIFIED
THIS BILL WILL IS -- RESPONSES
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HAVE A OUTBREAK
AND TRIES TO HELP WITH THE
SHARING OF INFORMATION.
TO ROB RELATED GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES AS WELL AS GIVING
CLARIFY NOT AUTHORITY FOR THE
HELP OFFICER.
FOR GIVING ORDERS TO THOSE
GOVERNMENT A IS IN ORDER TO STOP
THE SPREAD OF WHATEVER THE
OUTBREAK IS -- THE COUNTY PLEASE
IF THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IT COULD HAVE HELPED AFFECT THE
OUTCOME.
AND AS JUST A NOTE THE COUNTY IN
THE CITY OF ALSO BEEN WORKING
AND I THINK BELIEVE HAVE
IMPLEMENT ALL THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE
AUTHOR FROM THE OUT COME FROM
THAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MORE A TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE TO OUR
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE -- THE
THE BULK OF THE HAPPY CASES IN --
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WERE ACTUALLY
WITHIN THE CITY LIMITS AND WHILE
WE'RE NOT -- HISTORICALLY OR
FROM THE GOVERNMENT'S
PERSPECTIVE TYPICALLY -- THE
HEALTH OFFICERS WITHIN A REGION --
WE OBVIOUSLY HAD TO ACT AND WE I
WAS DIFFICULT TIME FOR US -- BUT
WE DID LEARN A LOT AND WE
LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS -- AND
I THINK THAT THE AUDIT AND AND A
LOT OF THE ACTIVITIES IN
CONVERSATIONS THEY'VE TAKEN
PLACE HAVE HELPED US UNDERSTAND --
THE GOOD THE BAD THE UGLY THAT
THOUGH WHAT WE WENT THROUGH AND
THIS BILL REALLY EMBODIES --
SOME OF THOSE GOOD LESSONS THAT
WE LEARNED -- WE HOPE NO ONE
ELSE HAS TO FACE WHAT WE FACE
BUT IF THEYDO THIS IS A GOOD
BILL TO HAVE IN PLACE TO REALLY
KEEP THE COMMUNICATION LINES
OPEN AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BACK MICROPHONE.
MANY HERE WITH CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
OKAY -- ARE THEIR WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE -- I'VE FIRST BUT
ADDS THAT WANT TO SAY I'M A
THANK YOU SIMILAR GLORIA FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY IS A PHYSICIAN WITH
BACKGROUND PUBLIC HEALTH
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
THAT -- WE NOT ONLY HAVE THE
TOOLS.
FOR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS BUT ALSO
THE LINES OF COMMUNICATION THERE
SO IMPORTANT.
DID THEY THINK PEOPLE FORGOT
HAVE FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE
SERIOUSNESS OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES -- AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD.
A TIME WHERE -- BETWEEN
ANTIBIOTICS AND VACCINATIONS AND
WIDESPREAD USE OF THOSE THAT --
VACCINATIONS THAT WE THAT WE
DIDN'T SEE AS MUCH AND THEN --
BUT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT --
THE AND ALSO.
AND SO FORTH BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT -- THAT TICKET
DID YOU NEED OF CONSTANT
VIGILANCE RIGHT THOSE THINGS
WHEN WHEN THEY START GETTING A
ROAD IT AWAY RIGHT -- WHETHER
IT'S VACCINATION RATES FALLING.
PEOPLE WHO AIM FOR ACCESS TO
CARE I KNOW THIS WAS.
A PARTICULAR EXACERBATED EMMA
AND THE HOMELESS -- POPULATION --
WINDOWS THE SOCIAL SUPPORTS FALL
AWAY -- THAN THAT FIRST OF ALL
AN IMMEDIATE RESPONSE IS NEEDED
BY PUBLIC HEALTH AND THEN A MORE
LONG TERM RESPONSE AS WELL -- TO
TO TRY DRESSES FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEMS AND I THINK THIS
PROVIDES VERY VALUABLE TOOLS SO
I WANT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TO CLOSE JUST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS QUITE
WELL -- AND I WOULD JUST ON
BEHALF OF THE TWENTY ONE PEOPLE
WHO DIED IN A SEVEN FORTY ONE I
DID I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE A MOTION.
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED FIVE NUMBER --
GONZALEZ AT SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HER TITLE LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING
RUBIO.
ALL RIGHT -- AND THEN YOU ALSO
HAVE AN IDEA.
BILL NUMBER ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE I DO IF
YOU'RE CHEN THE FULL NAME IS
CHAIRMAN RIO -- I WANT TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENT AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WHAT'S WORK ON
THIS BILL -- CHRONIC DISEASES
EXPENSIVE IN PATIENTS WITH
CHRONIC DISEASES IT UTILIZES
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
HEALTHCARE RESOURCES A CHRONIC
DISEASE ACCOUNTS 476% OF ALL
PHYSICIAN VISITS 81% OF ALL
HOSPITAL VISITS AND 91%.
OF ALL PRESCRIPTIONS FILLED MANY
PATIENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
MULTIPLE CHRONIC DISEASES DO NOT
REACH THE CLINICAL GOALS OF
THERAPY DUE TO SUB OPTIMAL
MEDICATION USE.
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES BY PROVIDING
GREATER COORDINATION OF
MEDICATIONS TAKEN BY THE STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE AND MOST ILL
POPULATIONS IN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM.
WITH ME TODAY HAVE A NUMBER OF
MINUTE WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AND ALLOW THEM TO DO
SOME CELLS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
TIM VALDERRAMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS WERE CO
SPONSOR OF THE MEASURE AND WE'RE
JOINED BY JONATHAN WATANABE
WHO'S AN EXPERT ON COMPREHENSIVE
MEDIC MEDICATION MANAGEMENT
SERVICES TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER.
I'M JUST ONE OF IN CLINICAL
FACULTY AT THE RISK CALIFORNIA'S
SAN DIEGO SKAGGS SCHOOL OF
PHARMACY AND PHARMACEUTICAL
SCIENCES I'M ALSO A HEALTH
ECONOMICS PROFESSOR AS WELL AS
DIRECTOR CORPSES BY TRAINING.
AND SO -- HOW IT REALLY CAME TO
THIS WAS THAT WE WOULD SEE
OFTENTIMES IN THE WORK WE WERE
DOING LOOKING AT THE COST OF
READ MISSIONS?
MORTALITY -- HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND EXTENDED VISITS RETURN
VISITS TO PHYSICIANS WE OFTEN
SEE THAT MET MUCH OF THAT WAS
DUE TO OPTIMISE.
MEDICATIONS NOT BEING OPTIMIZE
SO REALLY NOT BEING BUILT
EXACTLY FOR PURPOSE TO REGION
ACHIEVABLE CLINICAL GOAL THEIR
PRESCRIBED MEDICATION BUT WASN'T
EXACTLY IDEALIZED TO PREVENT.
FURTHER FOLLOW UP OR PREVENT
FURTHER SICKNESS.
AND SO WE WOULD OFTEN SEE THAT
THE THE COSTA REPORTED ON THIS
NATIONALLY WERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR.
WE OFTEN SAW THAT NUMBER
REPORTED ROUTINELY THAT THE COST
OF THIS NOT OPTIMIZED
MEDICATIONS ARE NOT GETTING THE
MEDICATIONS BILL FOR THE PURPOSE
OF OF MEETING THE GLOBAL GOAL
WAS COSTING CLOSE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
BUT THAT WAS BASED ON TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT NUMBERS AND A
LOT OF HAPPENED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT INCLUDE.
EXPANSION OF MEDICARE PART D.
CHANGES IN A CA INCREASING THE
COST AND IN GENERAL WITH WITH
MEDICAL COSTS AS WELL AS
MEDICATION COST.
SO WE CHOSE TO UPDATE THAT USING
MORE VALID SOURCES AND LOOKING
AT IF WE COULD GET A BETTER READ
ON THE CURRENT COSTS.
AND WE DID THAT THE ESTIMATE
TURNED INTO FIVE OR TWETY EIGHT
POINT FOUR BILLION OLLARS.
ANNUALLY FOR THE COST OF THIS
NON OPTIMIZE MEDICATION IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH EQUATES TO
ABOUT 16%.
OF TOTAL HEALTHCARE SPENDING
UNITED STATES SO REALLY AMOUNTS
TO A WE FOUND THIS NUMBER
UPDATED AND WHAT WE COULD DO
ABOUT THAT.
PART OF THAT WAS EXPANSION TO
LOOKING AT ONE SOLUTION WAS
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT WHICH WE DETAIL.
IN THAT -- PAPER AS A POTENTIAL
SOLUTION AND WE'RE SEEING THAT
THERE REALLY IS SOME SOME
STRIDES TO COULD BE MADE IF WE
IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY AND
SCALE UP.
OF THIS MODEL OF I THINK THAT
WE'VE THERE'S BEEN OUT SOME OF
THE REPORTS ABOUT THE THE
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME THAT THAT
PRESCRIBES ARE ABLE TO SPEND.
SPA SPEAKING WITH THEIR PATIENTS
I THINK THERE'S A REASON
ESTIMATE THAT ABOUT TWENTY SIX
SECONDS IS SPENT ON DISCUSSING.
THE EVIDENCE BASED PORTIONS OF A
NEW MEDICATION WITH A PATIENT
AND TWENTY SIX SECONDS A LOT TO
THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU'RE TRYING
TO TALK ABOUT A MEDICATION THEY
BE BE ON FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
BUT THAT'S WHAT WE FOUR TIMES
LONGER THAN A MINUTE SPEAK TODAY
AND SO REALLY THINKING ABOUT WE
COULD DO MORE AND THERE IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF DOING THIS IS IS
AT OUR DISPOSAL WE JUST HAVE TO
FIND A BETTER WAY.
OF DEPLOYING PHARMACISTS TO MEET
THIS OAL WHICH IS BECOMING I
THINK MORE MORE PORTENT AS OUR
POPULATION AGES AND COST ONLY GO
UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DAVID GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF AMERICA'S FISHING
GROUPS HAPPY TO BE HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US.
SORRY PROVIDERS RESPONSE FOR THE
CARE SOME EIGHTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'VE BEEN A
LONG PROPONENT OF TEAM BASED
CARE.
HAVING ALL PROFESSIONALS PARTS
OF THE TOP OF THE LICENSE THE
PHARMACIST IN PARTICULAR IN THE
SITUATION OUR EXAMPLE WE
QUALIFIED IN EDUCATED PROVIDE
THE SERVICE.
AND THEY CAN BE A KEY COMPONENT
FOR ACTUALLY REDUCING COSTS AND
INCREASING ADHERENCE AND HEALTH
CARE OUTCOMES ARE HAPPY BEYOND
SUPPORT IS A REASONABLE
INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SEE JOBS WITH NO
SOME WORKS WERE HERE BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS THANK YOU.
YOU.
BUT ALL THESE AGO REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT I THANK YOU.
LIZ HELMS ALSO CALIFORNIA CREDIT
CHEMICAL POLLUTION INSIST STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADAM KADMON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SEE NO THEIR
WITNESSES AND ORDERED ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY WELL FIVE THANK YOU AGAIN
THIS SUMMER GLORIA FOR ANOTHER
GREAT IDEA AND BILL AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD -- WOULD LIKE CLOSE SPEC
FASTER I THE I THANK YOU IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
OKAY AS A NEW FIRE.
CENTER -- SALAS US SECURITY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- OF
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT I DO HAVE
A QUESTION.
ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
I DIDN'T.
IN THE BILL YES A OKAY SO IT'S
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE --
AND RE REFER.
I REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER GONZALEZ I SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I STONE GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS I GROVE CONTATO LEYVA
OKAY THE BILL HAS TO GO TO FOOT
THE BILL ON CALL.
OKAY -- SO -- SO WELCOME I'M
GONNA HAVE TO STEP AWAY FROM ITS
I'M GOING TO GIVE HIM THE GAVEL
OVER -- TO SERRA GONZALEZ -- THE
CHAIR -- BUT THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT I WILL BUY MY THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I HOPE TO
BE BACK SHORTLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR
GRANT.
BEFORE YOU BEGAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH -- OUR
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF I THINK IT'S A GOOD IT'S A
WONDERFUL.
AND I THINK YOU'RE GONNA TELL US
HOW WONDERFUL THE BILL AS BUT
I'M GONNA SAY I DID IT REALLY
APPRECIATE -- THE WAY TRYING TO
DO HERE AND APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON THIS
BILL -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE THANKS
WHEN YOU YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THE PERSONAL INVOLVEMENT IN THE
REALLY REALLY STRONG SUGGESTIONS
TO HELP STRENGTHEN THIS BILL SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT VERY VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ARE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TODAY 2% AB ONE SIX SIX A BIT A
BILL TO PILOT THE PROVISION OF
MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PROFESSIONAL VIOLENCE PREVENTION
SERVICES.
I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND I DID WANT TO
THANK THE THE CHERRY COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH US ON ALL
THE AMENDMENTS.
I ALSO WANTED TO THANK THE
DIFFERENCE LAWCENTER FORTY
MUHAMMAD WITH THE NATIONAL
NETWORK OF HOSPITAL BASED
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS AND DOCTOR
SHOULDER WITH YOU SHOW A FOR
THEIR TECHNICAL SUPPORT ON THE
MEASURE.
THIS LEGISLATION ADDRESSES THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY THAT FAR TOO
MANY VICTIMS AGO OF GUN VIOLENCE
ARE AT HIGH RISK FOR RE ENTRY
AND RETALIATION.
STUDIES HAVE ESTIMATED THAT IN
URBAN AREAS OVER 40% OF PATIENTS
TREATED FOR VIOLIN INJURY SUCH
AS A SHOOTING ARE RE INJURED
WITHIN FIVE YEARS.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE ALARMING
TRENDS PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCHERS
IDENTIFIED HOSPITAL VASE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION PROGRAMS AS
ONE OF THE MOST INNOVATIVE AND
EFFECTIVE STRATEGIES FOR
REDUCING RATES OF FINERY ENTRIES.
THESE PROGRAMS BRING SPECIALLY
TRAINED AND CERTIFIED VIOLENCE
PREVENTION SPECIALIST INTO THE
HOSPITAL AND A UNIQUE MOMENT OF
OPPORTUNITY. TO WORK WITH
PATIENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THEIR HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AS HIGH RISK FOR
VIOLENT RE INJURY OR RETALIATION.
STUDIES HAVE REPEATEDLY
DEMONSTRATED THE SUCCESS OF SUCH
PROGRAMS YET THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CURRENTLY OPERATING IN ONLY A
FEW CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL LEADING
TO THOUSANDS OF MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES EVERY YEAR FOR
EFFECTIVE PREVENTION SERVICES TO
ADDRESS THE CYCLE OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN MANY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES.
AB ONE SIX SIX WOULD CREATE A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROJECT THAT
WOULD LEVERAGE FEDERAL MEDICAID
DOLLARS TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING STREAM FOR THESE
PROGRAMS.
THE PILOT WAS SUPPORT VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN OUR
STATE'S LARGEST COUNTIES ENSURE
A RIGOROUS EVALUATION TO HELP
DEMONSTRATE THE EFFECTIVENESS
AND IMPACT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
BY EXPANDING UTILIZATION OF THE
SERVICES THIS LEGISLATION WOULD
SAVE LIVES PROTECT PACKED PAYER
RESOURCES REDUCE BURDENS ON THE
MEDICAL IN JUDICIAL SYSTEMS AND
ADDRESS TROUBLING RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH OUTCOMES.
THIS BILL OR SEE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY AND IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF MEDICAL AND GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION EXPERTS INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS.
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF SURGEONS
COMMITTEE ON TRAUMA AND THE
DIFFERENCE LAW CENTER TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION OR
DR IAN BROWN A TRAUMA SURGEON AT
UC DAVIS AND JOHN TORE AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS THAT USED TO LIVE IN
OAKLAND.
WE ALSO OF ARLI FRY LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FROM THE DIFFERENCE
LAWCENTER HERE TO HELP ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
LIKE TO GO AHEAD.
HELLO AS WAS STATED MY NAME'S IN
BROWN.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY -- I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS AN
ATTENDING TRAUMA SURGEON FOR THE
PAST FOUR YEARS HERE AT UC DAVIS
I WANTED TO THIS FIELD. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP SOMEONE WHO
MIGHT BE HAVING THEIR WORST DAY --
THIS JOB GIVES ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN THAT AROUND
TOO MAYBE A SECOND CHANCE AND
AND SOMETHING BETTER OUT OF THAT --
IN MY TIME IS TRAUMA SURGEON
I'VE OPEN CHESS SOME CLOTHES
HOLES IN THE HEART OF PAST
DESTROYED LIVERS TAKEN A KIDNEYS
AND SPLEEN SAW WITH OF MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
BUT ALL TOO OFTEN -- WOULD
PERFORM THESE OPERATIONS ONLY TO
SEE THE SAME FACES AND AND
FAMILIES SHOW UP AGAIN DOWN THE
ROAD WITH SIMILAR PROBLEMS.
I'VE LEARNED THAT IF YOU REALLY
WANT TO SAVE A LIFE GETTING OFF
TO THE PATIENT OFF THE OPERATING
TABLE AND SAFELY THE HOSPITAL
DISCHARGES REALLY ONLY THE
BEGINNING STEP.
IN OTHER MEDICAL SITUATIONS SUCH
AS A HEART ATTACK WHEN YOU HAVE
AN EVENT LIKE THAT YOUR REST
EMERGENCY ROOM YOU'RE STABLE AS
AND THEN UPON THIS CHARGE.
AN ENTIRE PREVENTION PROGRAMS
INITIATING THE PATIENTS GIVEN
MEDICATIONS AND LIFESTYLE
MODIFICATION PLAN THAT HELPS YOU.
PREVENT YOU FROM COMING BACK TO
THE SAME EXACT SITUATION.
HISTORICALLY THAT'S NOT BEEN THE
CASE WITH VIOLENCE RELATED
TRAUMA RETREAT THE UNSHOT WOUND
TO THE STAB WOUND TO DISCHARGE A
PATIENT ONLY TO THE SAME EXACT.
SITUATION THAT BROUGHT THEM
THERE IN THE FIRST PLACE SO WE
NAY NO CHANGE.
AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT THIS RESULS
IN A VERY HIGH RATE OF VIOLENT
RE INJURY IT'S A REVOLVING DOOR.
THE ASSOCIATED COMMUNITY
PAINTING LOSSES CANNOT.
HAVE A PRICE PUT ON THEM.
THE SURGEONS WE CAN PATCH UP
JUST DAMAGED ORGANS.
BUT THIS IS AGAIN ONLY THE
BEGINNING HOSPITAL REYES
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
ARE AN INNOVATIVE STRATEGY AND
WAS GONE VIOLENCE IS TREATED AS
A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE.
THESE PROGRAMS CONNECT PEOPLE
WITH RESOURCES SUCH AS SOCIAL
SUPPORT HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE COPING SKILLS
PSYCHOSOCIAL PORT.
AND LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO NAME A
FEW THAT BEING SAID YOU CAN HAVE
ALL THE RESOURCES IN THE WORLD
AND STILL FAIL IF YOU CAN'T
EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE PEOPLE WITH A
FOUNDATION OF TRUST RESPECT AND
UNDERSTANDING AND THEN SUSTAIN
AN ENGAGEMENT.
THEREFORE THE CORNERSTONE OF
THESE INTERVENTIONS IS THE
INTERVENTION SPECIALIST THEY
HAVE AN ENORMOUS TASK BEING
GAUGING DEVELOPER POOR WITHIN AN
INCREDIBLY SMALL WINDOW OF TIME --
THIS REQUIRES CULTURAL
COMPETENCY IN A FIRSTHAND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PATIENT'S
LIFE EXPERIENCE WHICH CAN NOT BE
STATED ENOUGH.
SIMPLY PUT KILL PEOPLE HEAL
PEOPLE.
THEY'VE UNIQUE INSIGHT
PERSPECTIVE AND EXPERTISE THAT
IS UNMATCHED BY OTHER HOSPITAL
PERSONNEL THEY NOT ONLY BRING
YOU TO THE WATER HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY THEMSELVES
TO GOOD DRINK IN THE PAST.
NUMEROUS STUDIES CONDUCTED OVER
THE PAST TEN YEARS WILL CONFIRM
THAT THESE APPROACHES ONCE A
STANDARD NOT ONLY EXTREMELY COST
EFFECTIVE.
BUT SAVE LIVES THE PROPOSED BILL
HERE IS PROJECTED TO GENERATE
DIRECT COST SAVINGS EVEN IF IT
JUST PREVENTS TWENTY SEVEN
SHOOTINGS.
THIS DOESN'T EVEN BEGIN TO COVER
HOW IT WILL CHANGE COMMUNITY
DYNAMICS COMMUNITY PERCEPTIONS
OF VIOLENCE AND COMMUNITY
PERCEPTIONS OF SOCIAL SUPPORT.
ON A MORE PERSONAL LEVEL THESE
PROGRAMS GIVE ME SOMETHING
DIFFERENT OFFER PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS IT DOES
CHARGE GIVES ME AN OPPORTUNITY
OFFER REAL HOPE -- SOSUS
SURGEONS NURSES IN THE ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE STAFF.
WE HEAL PHYSICAL WOUNDS BUT
ULTIMATELY THESE ARE IN EFFECT
BANDAIDS IF WE CAN ADDRESS THE
REAL ISSUES.
REALLY CHANGING OF AYE FROM
HEALING A PERSON FROM VIOLENCE
RELATED TRAUMA REQUIRES A CHOICE
BY THAT PERSON.
WHICH ISN'T BLEW IT UP BY
PERSPECTIVE UNDERSTANDING AND
SUPPORT IN MY EXPERIENCE NO ONE
IS BETTER EQUIPPED TO DO THIS
WITH EMPATHY AND EFFECTIVENESS
THEN OUR INTERVENTION SPECIALIST.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL AND I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB.
ONE SIX SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN DORIS AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH YOU TO LIVE IN
OAKLAND.
AND I WORKED WITH THE YOUTH
ALIVE FOR OVER -- AND THEN THE
VANS PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION
FIELD FOR ALMOST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS -- PRESENT HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF ONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS THE CON THE CROSSFIRE
PROGRAM.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY THE FIRST
HOSPITAL BASED BOUNCE
INTERVENTION PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY.
WE CURRENTLY SERVE I'LL
INTRODUCE OR WE'VE BEEN SERVING
BOUNCE LEE INJURED YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR COM THE
CROSSFIRE STAFF RECEIVES
REFERRALS FOR INPATIENT AND
OUTPATIENT -- VICTIMS FROM ONE
OF THE THREE PROBLEMS CENTERS
THAT SERVE ALAMEDA COUNTY.
OUR PROGRAM AIMS TO RESPOND
WITHIN ONE HOUR.
AT FOUR BEDSIDE VISIT --
REFERRALS.
TYPICALLY OUR WORK BEGINS BY
ASSESSING THE PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL SAFETY AND FOR
POTENTIAL FOR RETALIATION.
IF THE CLIENT IS STABLE WE THEN
PROCEED TO ASSESS FOR SHORT TERM
AND LONG TERM NEEDS THAT WILL
HELP THE CLIENT RECOVER FROM THE
PHYSICAL INJURIES AND TRAUMA.
WE WILL DRIVE PARTICIPANTS TO
MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS LINK THEN
RESOURCES SUCH AS MEDICARE OUT
AND VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD.
AND OFTEN PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR THINGS SUCH ASFOOD DIAPERS AND CLOTHING.
I'LL GIVE YOU A SHORT A BRIEF
STUDY ON ONE OF OUR THE
INSTANCES THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
SUPPORT.
IT WAS A DOUBLE SHOOTING -- THE
VICTIM WAS A TWENTY ONE YEAR OLD
FEMALE WITH A GUNSHOT WOUND TO
HER STOMACH AND HER THREE YEAR
OLD SON WITH A GUNSHOT WOUND TO
THE ARM.
OF THE PROGRAM WAS ABLE TO
SUPPORT HER INITIALLY WITH
COMPLETING AND MEDICARE APPLIQUE.
THAT IN TURN HELPED HER.
RECEIVED OR GET TO SURGERIES TO
REPAIR INTESTINES.
WE WERE ABLE TO REFER HER TO
OUTPATIENT SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AS WELL AS ENGAGING
HER AN ONGOING MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT. FOR HER SON WE WERE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IN LINKING HIM
TO PHYSICAL THERAPY FOR HIS ARM.
WHICH WOULD LATER LEARN WITHOUT
THERAPY SERVICES -- HIS ARM MAY
HAVE BEEN AMPUTATED.
AND WE ALSO REFERRED HIM INTO
MENTAL HEALTH THERAPY.
AND IS REALLY CRITICAL IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE THAT ACTUALLY LEAD
TO THE PROSECUTION OF THE
SUSPECTS THE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
INCIDENT.
SO WHY BONDS INTERVENTION.
INITIALLY THIS PATIENT WAS IN
FEAR FOR HER LIFE AS WELL AS
FOUR SONS.
A KEY COMPONENT TO PROVIDING
SERVICES BUILDING A STRONG
TRUSTING RELATIONSHIP.
WE ACCOMPLISH THIS BY HAVING
TRAINED.
STAFF HIRED FROM COMMUNITIES
SIMILAR TO OUR VICTIMIZE CLIENTS
AND HAVE THEM WORK WITH THE
PARTICIPANTS.
THIS IN TURN HELPS.
BY APPROACHING FOLKS WITH THE
TRAUMA INFORMED APPROACH AND
PROVIDING THEM.
WITH THE SERVICES THAT
PRIORITIZE THEIR HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND SAVES LIVES.
ALSO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TESTIFYING HERE
TODAY.
AND REITERATE YOUTH LIVE SUPPORT
FOR A BI.
ONE SIXTY SIX AND I THINK WE'RE
AT SIX MINUTES ALREADY SO INCUR
YOU THE LAST SPEAKER.
OKAY GREAT WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY THAT WAS
WONDERFUL SPECIALLY BEING MY
FIRST TIME SHARING -- ANY
COMMITTEE MEETING ON THE SENATE
SIDE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER GABRIEL
AND TO ALL OF THAT -- THE
SPEAKERS TODAY AND SO ON NEXT.
I YES AND WE'LL GO TO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IF THEY CAN COME UP.
DISCUSS THE WHOLE THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN THE
HAVING OUR SAY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
KRIS AQUINO'S HERE ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
IMAGINE REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT.
PACKAGES VOICE.
ON BEHALF OF OUR GIFFORD
LAWCENTER THANK A VOLUNTEER
SUPPORT AS WELL AWESOME THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY AYE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
NO OKAY.
I'M WILL TAKE ANY OTHER THERE'S
NO OTHER COMMUNITY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IT'S JUST ME BUT I WILL
SAY I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
THINK THIS IS GREAT WORK --
ESPECIALLY AS MANY OF US
REPRESENT AREAS THAT
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE BEEN PLAGUED
WITH GUN VIOLENCE AND SAY THIS
IS REALLY WONDERFUL.
I THINK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
A FOR YOUR KIND COMMENTS SENATOR
AND JUST TO REITERATE WHAT -- I
THINK THE WITNESSES SAID A LOT
OF WHAT NEEDED TO BE SAID BUT
THIS IS A REAL -- OPPORTUNITY I
THINK FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO
SOMETHING. TO APPROACH FOLKS AT
A GOLDEN MOMENT OF OPPORTUNITY --
IN THEIR TRAUMA AND TO REALLY
HOPEFULLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
SAVE LIVES AND ALSO PROTECT
TAXPAYER RESOURCES SO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
OKAY AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND PUT THIS ON CALL AS WE NEED
MORE MEMBERS OF COURSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
AND
ALL RIGHT WILL PICK THIS
BACK UP.
BRING UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
YOU'D LIKE TO COME UP PLEASE ON
AB.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN HELLO --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE.
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN IS TECH
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP BILL. TO A.
B. SIX TWO SIX WHICH ESTABLISHED
A MICROENTERPRISE HOME KITCHEN
OPERATIONS AS A NEW TYPE OF
RESTRICTED FOOD FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU I
WOULD HAVE -- WITH ME CHOI WING
FROM THE COOK LANCE WHO CAN
SPEAK ON THE BILLS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS CHARLIE WONG AND I WORK FOR
THE CC ALLIANCE.
ALLIANCE WAS THE PRIMARY SPONSOR
AB SIX TWO SIX THE HOMEMADE FOOD
OPERATIONS ACT IT HAS BEEN
WORKING ON LEGALIZING HOME
COOKING FOR FOUR YEARS.
WE REPRESENT THOUSANDS OF COOKS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER'S FARMERS
SMALL BUSINESS SUPPORTERS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS.
LEGALIZING HOME COOKING HAS WIDE
SUPPORT ACROSS CALIFORNIA LAST
YEAR OVER SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
SIGNED A PETITION THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE CALLED THE ROAD THERE
LIKE TO OFFICIALS.
AND ALMOST A HUNDRED
ORGANIZATION SIGNED ON TO
SUPPORT AB.
SIX TWO SIX BUT SINCE AB SIXTY
SIX WENT INTO EFFECT IN JANUARY
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
INTERESTED COUNTIES ON
IMPLEMENTING HOME COOKING
PERMITS.
THE COUNTIES IN SLOW TO
IMPLEMENT BECAUSE OF CONFUSION
AROUND ISSUE AROUND SOME ISSUES
PRIMARILY OF JURISDICTION.
AB THREE SEVEN SEVEN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND CREATES MORE CLARITY
NOT ONLY AROUND JURISDICTION BUT
ALSO AND PUBLIC HEALTH
REQUIREMENTS PERMITTING
INSPECTION PROCESSES AND THIRD
PARTY THIRD PARTY PLATFORM
ISSUES.
THIS BILL REPRESENTS TIRELESS
ONGOING COLLABORATION BETWEEN
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AND HOME
COOKING ADVOCATES AND REPRESENTS
ALL INTEREST INCLUDING THE C. C.
D. H..
SHE ASKED HOW ADVOCACY SACK AS
WELL AS THE COMPLIANCE.
OTHER THAN A HANDFUL SMALL
CITIES WE HAVE ALMOST NO
OPPOSITION WE KNOW WE CAN'T FIX
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CITIES
AND COUNTIES WITH THE FOOD.
COURAGE AND EXPECT CITIES THE
PASTORAL ORDINANCES TO ADDRESS
ISSUES AS THEY ARISE AND TRUST
THEM TO GOVERN THEMSELVES
SUCCESSFULLY.
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT
ALLOWING HOME COOKS MOSTLY WOMEN
IMMIGRANTS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
TO GENERATE INCOME AND START
BUSINESSES THAT MAKE SENSE FOR
THEIR SKILL SETS AND THEIR
LIFESTYLES.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY BOOK.
MADAM CHAIR JOHN MALONE OF THE
HOPE OF THE ASSOCIATION
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WE ALL THE FOR
THE FOOD COPS WITH THE
INSPECTORS THEY GO OUT --
NOTWITHSTANDING SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WE HAD WITH THE BILL
LOST HERE YOUR WORK ACT
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS VERY VERY
WELL ARTICULATES.
WHY WE SUPPORTING THIS PROVISION --
THIS BILL THIS YEAR IT ADDRESSES
SOME OF WHAT WE SAW THE PROBLEMS
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAD WITH THE
ORIGINAL BILL.
WILL BE VERY PLEASED WE DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US WE BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO
MAKE THIS MUCH BETTER TO
IMPLEMENTED A MUCH SAFER AS WELL
SO THANK YOU AGAIN.
FOR PASSING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THIS CAN BE BURKE WITH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT.
CHAU GIVENS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE
TECHNICAL CLEAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
JONATHAN CLAIMS AFTER THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO I KIND OF FALL INTO
THAT TWEENER CATEGORY WE'VE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF CONCERNS.
NEARLY AROUND THE AREA RELATED --
TO AS THE ONE OF THE SPONSORS
Là TO THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
CITIES AND COUNTIES.
IN THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO WE HAVE
A GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
CITIES BUT WE HAVE CITIES THAT
WANT THIS PROGRAM WE HAVE OTHER
CITIES THAT DON'T WANT THIS
PROGRAM.
AND AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE
COUNTY DOES NOT SEE THAT WE HAVE
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
CERTAIN CITIES IN OR OUT WE
EITHER OFTEN AND DON'T OFTEN.
KNOWN COOPER SPEND PROGRAM AND
WE THINK THAT SHOULD BE CHANGED
OTHERWISE WE AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THE OTHER -- CLEAN UP FROM TO
LAST YEAR'S PROPOSALS.
MANAGER DAVEY JOHNSON TO HAVE
ONE OF THOSE SMALL CITIES THAT
DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
WITH THIS BILL SOUTH PASADENA --
HE HAS -- BEEN VERY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PREEMPTION
AND THE ABILITY OF THE COUNTY TO
MAKE THE DECISION FOR ALL
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND HAVE THEM
HAVE NO SAY IN WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS --
THEY'RE VERY VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH -- QUé A
RISK AND THEY THINK THAT THIS
DECISION IS RIGHT WE LEFT WITH
THE ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE AND
HAVING THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
MAKE THE DECISION FOR ALL EIGHTY
EIGHT CITIES.
WE THINK IS AN OVERREACH WE
THINK THERE'S ANOTHER WAY THAT
THE COUNTY IF THEY WANTED TO
OFTEN THEY CAN OPT IN AND HAVE A
DOUBLE LOCKED IN.
SO THE COUNTY COULD OPT IN AND
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO BE THE
HEALTH OFFICER FOR THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES IN THOSE CITIES THAT
WANTED TO JOIN THEM AND OPTING
IN COULD ALLOW THOSE BUSINESSES
IN THOSE LOCATIONS.
THAT IS A WAY THAT WOULD WE
WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT
BILL -- BUT THE BILL'S IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED MAKES THE
DECISION TAKES A DECISION
ENTIRELY OUT OF ELECTED
OFFICIALS DECISION MAKING AND WE
ARE VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO THE
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- RIGHT SO
I WILL -- SO WE'VE TAKEN
OPPOSITION ALREADY AND THEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- WE ARE CONTINUE TO BE
OPEN.
TO ANY TECHNICAL -- CHANGES THAT
COULD POTENTIALLY GIVE -- LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WORKING WITH
COUNTY TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS.
PROGRAM ALSO A SHARE WITH YOU
THAT THE WE'RE EXCITED TO INFORM
THE COMMITTEE THAT FIRST COUNTY.
IN THE STATE IS RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TO HAVE ADOPTED THESE -- THIS UP
POLICY.
ARE NOT EVERY CITY IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY IS INTERESTED IN DOING
THIS AND REALLY LEAVING IT TO
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO BE
ABLE.
TO ULTIMATELY SET UP THEIR
STRUCTURE -- TO HAND UP THE
BUSINESS LICENSES AND OF COURSE
OUR FLLEN SUIT WITH THE COUNTY.
I REGULATIONS THAT THAT THAT ARE
IN PLACE AND THAT ARE NOW BEING --
CLARIFY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION THIS MATTER
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR APPLE.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I WANT THANK
YOU.
GARCIA -- FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
ISSUE I KNOW THAT WE HAD A
LITTLE BIT OF A DISTANCE OF
PREVIOUS FELL BUT I THINK THIS
THIS CERTAINLY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AND NEEDED.
A CHANGE -- SO IS THERE A MOTION
ON THE BILL.
KATE'S MOVE BY A CENTER GONZALEZ --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I STONE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I'D GROWTH HER TADO
LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY YEAH YOU HAVE TO VOTE SAY
OF THE TWO THAT ARE HERE AND
WE'LL KEEP THE ITEM ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY I I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM IF YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND COME UP -- AND THEN ACTUALLY
JUST -- DID.
WE DID THE SO ACTUALLY I'M IF
YOU MA'AM GUYS BEFORE WE BEGIN --
GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
BECAUSE AND AGAIN THANK YOU --
CENTER GONZALEZ FOR CHAIRING.
IS THERE A MOTION ON ITEM.
THREE EIGHTY ONE SIXTY SIX OKAY
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER AYE
GONZALEZ -- EXCEPT THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AND I AM THREE
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY SIX AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED --
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PAM HI CAN I
STONE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW
HER TADO LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING
RUBIO.
OKAY SO THAT THOSE TWO VOTES
IT'S ON CALL OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MEMBER
BLOOM WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB SEVENTY FIVE WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE UPDATES
THE CURRENT HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODES THAT REGULATE GAMETE BANKS.
THIS IS A TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO
BETTER STREAMLINE THE TRANSFER
OF IMPORTANT DONOR MEDICAL
INFORMATION FROM ONE BANK TO
ANOTHER.
THE BILL ALIGNS THE EXISTING
STATE CODES TO HARMONIZE WITH
THE FDA'S REGULATIONS FOR DONOR
IDENTITY REQUIREMENTS AND TISSUE
TRANSFERS.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES
BANKS THAT RECIEVE DONOR GAMETE.
TO MAINTAIN THE CONTACT
INFORMATION OF THE BANK FROM
WHICH THE SAMPLES WERE RECEIVED.
THE ORIGINATING BANK WILL
MAINTAIN MORE DETAIL DONOR
INFORMATION TO ENSURE THE
TRANSFER OF DAMAGE FROM ONE BANK
TO ANOTHER WILL NOT AFFECT.
THE FAMILY'S ABILITY TO HAVE
ACCESS TO PROPERTY OWNER MEDICAL
INFORMATION.
THE LEGISLATION ALSO UPDATES THE
DEFINITION OF DAMAGE.
TO BOTH SIDES AND EMBRYOS TO
BETTER ALIGN STATE LAWS WITH
FEDERAL LAWS.
THIS BILL HELPS BETTER REGULATE
TO GAMETE BANKS TO PROVIDE ALL
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN CONCEIVED
FROM DONOR TISSUES.
WITH THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO MAKE INFORMED HEALTH
DECISIONS. TO TESTIFY HAVE
VALLEY'S A GOLF FROM THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE.
MEDICINE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME ISMY
LEASE THAT I'LL REPRESENTING
AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE.
A CO SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE AND
ESSENTIALLY AGO WITH MEMBER HAS
ALREADY STATED TODAY -- EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE IS THE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP OF LAST
YEAR'S AB.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR RELATED
TO GAMETE DONOR IDENTITY
INFORMATION FOR CHILDREN
CONCEIVED USING ASSISTED
REPRESENTATIVE TECHNOLOGIES --
LAST YEAR'S AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FOUR WAS A SIGNIFICANT
UNDERTAKING -- WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY UPDATED THE
UNIFORMED PARENTAL ACT --
THROUGHOUT THE FAMILY CODE
RELATING TO CORRENTE EDGE --
HOWEVER GIVEN THE VOLUME OF
CHANGES AND SINCE SIGNING OF THE
BILL WE RECEIVED INFORMATION
FROM GAMETE BANKS THAT THERE IS.
INCONSISTENCIES BETWEEN --
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FOUR AND FTA
REGULATION SPECIFICALLY WITH
REGARDS TO THE COLLECTION AND
DISCLOSURE OF DONOR IDENTITY
INFORMATION AND MEDICAL
INFORMATION -- SO EIGHTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE FULL BETTER
SYNCHRONIZE AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH FDA
REGULATIONS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RIVAL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THE OFFICE SO YOU IN CALIFORNIA.
TAMMY MARTIN WITH EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN PROUD SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS REMEMBERS.
AS OUR MOTION.
THE MOVE A SIR GONZALEZ SO.
THANK YOU SIMILAR BLOOM FOR
BRING THIS BOARD AND AND
DRESSING ANYTHING IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
YES I WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ADULT AND
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY SO THE IT'S BEEN
MOVED THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY -- SECRETARY -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I STONE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROW A TOMATO.
LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO I THANK YOU THAT BILL HAS
THREE VOTES -- WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY CENTER HOLDEN WELCOME.
AND I THINK -- YOU HAVE TWO
ITEMS ONE WHICH IS ON CONSENT SO
WHAT THIS WILL HAVE ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB.
NINE FOURTEEN WELCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
NINE FOURTEEN THIS BILL SEEKS TO
DECREASE RATES OF DEATH AND
RECIDIVISM BY IMPROVING ACCESS
TO HEALTH SERVICES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW PERSONS MEDI
CAL BENEFITS OR TERMINATED AFTER
WHEN YOU'RE BEING AN INMATE.
OF A PUBLIC INSTITUTION LATER
WHEN THAT INDIVIDUAL IS ELIGIBLE
FOR RELEASE.
CDC OUR PROGRAMS HELP THEM
REAPPLY FOR MEDI CAL BENEFITS.
FOURTEEN A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
BEFORE THE RELEASE DATE.
ALTHOUGH THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN A ROLLING
PEOPLE INTO MEDI CAL.
YOU CAN STILL TAKE A WEEKS AFTER
RELEASE BEFORE THEY HVE ACCESS
TO CARE AND MEDICATIONS.
THE SPIRIT IS CRITICAL FOR ALL
PEOPLE FACING REINTEGRATION AND
IS ESPECIALLY CRITICAL FOR THOSE
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCIES OR MENTAL ILLNESSES.
pACCESS TO MEDICINE THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE VULNERABLE TO
THE CONDITIONS THAT MAY HAVE
INITIALLY GOTTEN THEM ARRESTED.
IN ADDITION TO AN INCREASE
RESERVE RICK RISK OF RECIDIVISM
PEOPLE FACING REINTEGRATION
PLACE VERY HIGH RATES OF
MORTALITY.
IN THE TWO WEEKS FOLLOWING
RELEASE OF FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PERSON IS TWELVE POINT 7% TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
PREVENTABLE CAUSE.
DURING THESE CRITICAL TWO WEEKS
DURING OVERDOSE OR I'M SORRY
DURING THESE TWO WEEKS DRUG
OVERDOSE -- VASCULAR DISEASE
HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE WERE THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH.
AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL SUSPEND
MEDI CAL BENEFITS AND REDID
TURMAN ELIGIBILITY THROUGH A
SIMPLIFIED YEARLY PROCESS FOR
INDIVIDUALS UNDER THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX THAT BECOME INMATES.
OF A PUBLIC INSTITUTION.
SUSPENSION WILL ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAD MEDI CAL BENEFITS
BEFORE ENTERING JAIL WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MEDICAL BENEFITS
IMMEDIATELY UPON RELEASE.
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS ESSENTIAL
TO MAINTAINING POSITIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES AND PREVENTING COSTLIER
FORM.
HEALTHCARE DOWN THE ROAD.
AB NINE FOURTEEN WILL ENSURE.
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR BENEFITS IMMEDIATELY UPON
RELEASE.
THUS IMPROVING HEALTH OUTCOMES
FOR GOING TO BE POPULATIONS AND
IMPROVING RECIDIVISM RATES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER RIVAL.
THANK YOU WITNESSES A SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY -- TO PUT IT SHORTLY
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE ALREADY SOLVED PEOPLE WHO
ARE LARGELY IN CONTROL OF THE
STATE AND ROLLING THEM INTO A
STATE PROGRAM SHOULDN'T BE A
PROBLEM.
BUT WITH SOME OF THE NUANCES OF
THE MEDIC HOW PROGRAM ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT PEOPLE HAVE IS NOT
ONLY DO THEY NEED TO BE ENROLLED
IN MEDICARE OUT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS OR MANAGED CARE
PLAN.
IN ORDER TO GET SERVICES SO BY
SUSPENDING INSTEAD OF
TERMINATING AND RE ENROLLING WE
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS.
AND THEN I'D ALSO JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT IN ADDITION TO THE
FACT THAT SIXTEEN STATES AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA HAVE
ALREADY DONE THIS WITHOUT.
YOU THIS GUY FALLING IN -- SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE HAVE HAD A
MUCH SIMPLIFIED DANIEL TO READ
TO TERMINATION -- IN MANY
COUNTIES UP 240% OF THE
POPULATION WHO ARE UNDER SIXTY
FIVE ARE ABLE TO RE ENROLL
AUTOMATICALLY WHERE THE COUNTY
WORKERS JUST LOOKING AT WHAT'S
IN THE COUNTY FILE OR DOING
THINGS ELECTRONICALLY.
THIS POPULATION IS EVEN MORE
AMENABLE TO THAT SO THE IDEA
THAT WE COULD DO AS SIMPLIFIED
ELIGIBILITY READ A TERMINATION
FOR THIS POPULATION IS EVEN ALL
THE MORE BENEFICIAL AND TO NOT
REITERATE EVERYTHING THAT THE
AUTHOR JUST.
SO WELL STATED YOU KNOW WHEN
PEOPLE LEAVE PRESENT THEIR
ABILITY TO SURVIVE ON THE
OUTSIDE WHETHER IT'S ACCESS TO
HOUSING WHETHER IT'S ACCESS TO
FOOD OR ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
REALLY DETERMINES THEIR ABILITY
TO RE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DRIVE OUT.
HELLO THIS IS A SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS VERENIGDE TING BUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RATTLE
HAGER FOR THE HEALTH THE AFTER
DISASSOCIATION WERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO SHOW MUCH ARM
YOU HAVE A CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MARKETS GO THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA BENEFIT HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
TIME REVIEW WITH THE COUNTY BE
ABLE HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU ANYWAY THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
XENON COMMITTEE MEMBER QUESTIONS --
SO -- SEVERAL NIGHTS ONE THANK
YOU.
TRIM HIS BRING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I MEAN THE FACT THAT WE EXPECT.
SO IN THIS DISCHARGED FROM.
IN JAIL OR PRISON.
AND NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
TREATMENT THEY RECEIVED WHILE
THEY'RE THERE OF WHAT MIGHT HAVE
LED THEM TO BE AN JAIL BUT
CERTAINLY.
OF THE TREATMENT AND THEN EXPECT
THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND NOT IN
THE BACK.
IN JAIL OR PRISON.
OUT OF MONEY TAXPAYERS HAVE TO
PAY TO KEEP THEM IN THAT JAIL
AND PRISON.
I MEAN THIS MAKES SO MUCH SENSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH RAIN THIS BILL
FORD.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THE MOTION.
OKAY IT'S A NEW FIGHT CENTER
RUBIO OF WHICH LIKE THE CLOTHES.
I THINK YOU DID A MARVELOUS OF
FOR ME BAKING.
GIVE OKAY SO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AND REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AND I PAN AYE STONE GONZALEZ AND
SALAS I'D GROW.
HER TADO LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
OKAY YOUR THREE VOTES THAT'S
WHAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW I WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OKAY SO FOR ALL OF YOU WATCHING
ON YOUR TV'S THAT THEY WERE WAIT
STILL WAITING FOR SOME MEMBERS
IN THIS AREA AND SALAS AND
WALDRON HAVE BILLS THAT ARE.
BEFORE US TODAY SO.
AND LET YOUR RESPECTIVE MEMBERS
KNOW WHO WE ARE READY
.
SHE WELL AWAITING THE SAYS
SOMEONE ONE OF ITS FIRST OF ARE
THERE ANY EXTRACTIONS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHTS AND BY CENTER RUBIO
SO WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR DOES ITEMS OF
TO AB FORTY THREE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
AND NUMBER SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
SIXTY NINE ITEM OF THIRTEEN
EIGHTY ELEVEN FIFTY TWO AND ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN OF A. B. --
FOURTEEN FORTY THREE SO
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PAN HI CAN I STONE
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO
LEYVA MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE OKAY CONSENT CALENDAR
THREE VOTES WILL BUT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL
.
A SIMILAR NAZARIAN WELCOME.
SO.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
TEN THIRTY ONE WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
HI I'D LIKE TO FIRST THE START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT ON REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
A. B. TEN THIRTY ONE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO DEVELOP
REGULATIONS FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
CONTINUUM OF CARE. FOR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER FOR YOUTH UNDER AGE.
TWENTY ONE AB TEN THIRTY ONE
WOULD ALSO ENABLE COUNTIES AND
PROVIDERS TO PROPERLY CLAIM AND
BILL FOUR EPS D. T. ENTITLEMENT
SERVICES UNDER DRUG MEDIC HOW.
BY REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT AS
BILLING CODES FOR COVERED A
SUBSTANCE USED.
P. S. D. T. BENEFIT. TOO MANY
ACRONYMS KIND OF CREATES IT.
IT'S CONFUSION SO MY APOLOGIES.
SINCE THERE IS A FEDERAL MATCH
WITH THE P. S. T. T. THE ABILITY
TO BILL FOR THE SERVICES WOULD
DRAW DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS FOR
YOUTH TREATMENT. FOR CONTEXT UP
290% OF ADULTS WITH SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER DEVELOPED A PATTERN
OF ALCOHOL OR DRUG DEPENDENCE
BEFORE AGE EIGHTEEN UNDER THE
FEDERAL A. B..
D. E. P. S. T. T. THANK YOU.
BENEFIT MEDICAID AND ROLL YOU
ARE ENTITLED TO EACH APPROPRIATE
CARE FOR ANY IDENTIFIED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
EVER MEDICAID SERVICE PAYMENTS
ALONE ARE INSUFFICIENT FOR THE
CAPITAL AND OVERHEAD COSTS
NEEDED. TO BUILD NEW COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
CHOSEN TO INVEST IN A ROBUST
SYSTEM OF SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
CARE. FOR UNINSURED AND MEDICAID
ELIGIBLE YOUTH WHILE COUNTIES
MANAGE PUBLICLY FUNDED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS ELECT SYSTEMIC.
GUIDANCE AND DEDICATED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE SET OF SERVICES
BUT DISPONIBLE POPULATION.
ESTABLISHING STATEWIDE STANDARDS
AND UPDATING BUILDING CODES WILL
BE VALUABLE TOOLS FOR YOUTH
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OUR RANDALL
HAGAR WITH FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION AND TOM
RENT FREE FROM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
OKAY THANK YOU WITNESSES ABORT
RANDALL MY FLIP A COIN AND
RECITED AND I I GOT TO GO FIRST
THIS TIME SO HAD TAUGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TOM RENT FREE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS.
THE I THINK WE'RE ALL AWARE OF
THE IMPACT THAT THE CURRENT DRUG
CRISIS IS HAVING ON ON YOUNG
PEOPLE HAVE LESSONS I MEAN WE'RE
HEARING MORE FROM -- EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE ADOLESCENTS AND
YOUNG ADULTS ENTERING A R. E.
OURS EITHER USING DEPENDENT ON
OR ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS OR IN
SOME VERY SAD CASES EVEN
OVERDOSE.
AT THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF YOUTH
WITH THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS%
ARE MOST EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSED
IN AGE SPECIFIC TREATMENT
SETTINGS THAT OFFER A CONTINUUM
OF CARE.
FROM OUT REGION SCREENING
THROUGH ASSESSMENT -- DIAGNOSIS
TREATMENT -- FAMILY INTERVENTION
RECOVERY SUPPORT OF THE THE THE
EARLY PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT MANDATE
EPS THE T. -- UNDER THE FEDERAL
LAW IS VERY BROAD AND BASICALLY
SAYS THAT MEDICAID ELIGIBLE
YOUTH ARE ENTITLED TO WHATEVER
SERVICES ARE NEEDED TO
AMELIORATE A HEALTH CONDITION
INCLUDING -- SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER -- MOST OF IT MOST
PUBLICLY FUNDED THERE SHOULD BE.
POPULATION AND HAS -- SOME WOMEN
THIS ARIAN SAID THE STATE IS NOT
REALLY INVESTED IN A CONTINUUM
OF CARE FOR YOU WITH WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SO WHAT
WE'RE JUST TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL.
IS BY REQUIRING -- DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS AND AND
REGULATIONS FOR A CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND TO ESTABLISH BILLING
CODES UNDER EPS D. T. THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES.
WE HOPE TO BETTER ABOUT BE ABLE
TO SERVE THESE YOUTH WHO ARE WHO
ARE IN NEED OF CARE THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RANDALL HAGER
FOR IT -- THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WE ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THIS AND I THAT
YOU'VE JUST HEARD SOME VERY
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY WON'T --
REPEAT ANY OF THAT I THINK ONE
THING THAT STRUCK ME AS I WAS
PREPARING FOR THIS HEARING AS I
WAS RE READING A HEALTHY KIDS
SURVEY OF SCHOOLS.
AND THERE'S A VERY STRIKING --
AND RECENT DATA IN THERE ABOUT --
KIDS INVOLVEMENT WITH DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL -- BY THE SEVENTH GRADE --
ABOUT 729% OF THE KIDS HAVE
ACTUALLY GOT SOME SORT OF
SUBSTANCE USE -- INVOLVEMENT.
BY THE LEVIN GRADE IN THAT GOES
UP 229% AND THAT COULD BE
ANYTHING FROM HAVING A SINGLE
DRINK WITH A THIRTY DAY PERIOD.
TO FIVE DRINKS IN SUCCESSION IN
A SINGLE EPISODE IT COULD BE
USING PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
ILLICITLY IT COULD BE A WHOLE
HOST OF THINGS.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE VERY LARGE
NUMBERS THAT'S ONE IN FOURTEEN
AT THE SEVENTH GRADE LEVEL SO I
THINK IT DOES TELL US THAT WE DO
NEED TO GET MOVING AND WE NEED A
SYSTEM OF CARE.
AND WE WILL WE NEED SOME --
ABILITY TO OFFER -- A
REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM SO THAT
PROVIDERS CAN STEP UP AND
DEVELOP THE PROGRAMS AND HIRE
THE PEOPLE INTO THE WORK THANK
YOU.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RENDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROBERT HARRIS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
THESE BILLING CODES ARE
IMPORTANT KIDS RIGHT NOW.
CAN'T GET THE TREATMENT LET'S
SAY IF.
THEY ARE ONLY DIAGNOSED WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
OKAY THANK YOU NAME OR EXIST
POSITION.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. FOR ME THEY TING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH
HOSPITALS ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ABOUT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CHECK AGAINST THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS ARE THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON THAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT WELL -- I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND CERTAINLY WE NEED TO TRY.
TO INCREASE ACCESS FOR SUMS USE
TREATMENT -- FOR OUR YOUTH AND
SORRY THIS IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD IN DOING THAT -- IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THE MOVE BY SERIK
UNTUK GONZALEZ -- WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES INTERNS AREA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU OKAY SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AT TWO AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI PAN AYE STONE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW FURTADO LEYVA
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
OKAY OF THREE VOTES THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW -- WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL AND OTHER MEMBERS ARE
ANOTHER COMMITTEES HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL BE ADDING ON WE'LL GET
THE BILL OUT ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
OKAY SO I THINK WE ARE STILL
WAITING FOR MEMBERS -- HI I MAY
TAKE THE OP.
OKAY.
WELL MAYBE I WHILE WE'RE WAITING --
SINCE THIS LAST BILL HAD TO DO
WITH THE PST T. OTHERWISEKNOWN
AS EARLY PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT SERVICES
I WOULD MAKE NOTE THE HISTORY OF
THAT PROGRAM BECAUSE THAT
PROGRAM WAS ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED --
THIS PART OF THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM -- AFTER BECAUSE OF THE
VIETNAM WAR AND WHAT.
WAS NOTED WAS THAT -- WHEN THE
ARMY WAS DOING THE DRAFT THEY
NOTED THAT MANY OF THE -- YOUNG
MAN AT THE TIME WHO THEY WERE
DRAFTING.
HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT PREVENTED
THEM FROM BEYOND THE SERVE IN
THE MILITARY.
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WAS A
ACTUALLY NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUES THAT CHILDREN WERE NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
AND SO THAT'S WHY YOU'D BE STT
WAS PASSED BY CONGRESS TO
ADDRESS THAT IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUES JUST A LITTLE.
TRIVIA.
PEOPLE TO KEEP IN MIND BUT THE
PST HE'S STILL WITH US AND
CERTAINLY IS AVAILABLE FOR A
BROADER SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
NOT ONLY FOR MENTAL HEALTH BUT
FOR OTHER THINGS AND CERTAINLY
FOR SUBSTANCE USE AS WELL.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR MEMBERS
THOUGH
[inaudible]
SO ACTION
-- DID YOU WANT TO
TAKE THOSE ON CALL.
IN THIS YOU WANT TO WAIT FOR A
FULL COMPLIMENT BUT I'M HAPPY
OKAY WHATEVER YOU WOULD LIKE.
ETHICS.
MAYBE OUT OF DO YOU HAVE TO GO
ANYWAY.
SO NOW WE ARE WAITING FOR EACH --
SOMEONE OVER SALAS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN ARE SOME MEMBER WALDRON
ITEM THE FOURTEEN WE HAVE
DISPOSE OF THE REMAINING ITEMS
AND INCLUDING OF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SO ALL THE OTHER ITEMS
ON CALL
.
WELCOME SUMMER SALAS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TEN FIFTY EIGHT
WELCOME.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
BUT RICHARD MEMBERS -- PRESENT
BEFORE YOU SOMEBODY WILL TEN
FIFTY A. WERE CREATED
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP
AND IDENTIFY.
ADMINISTRATIVE LEGAL BARRIERS TO
THE DELIVERY OF INTEGRATED
BEHAVIORAL MENTAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WITH CO OCCURRING.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS A MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS REQUIRE DH CS
TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADDRESS THOSE BARRIERS --
MEMBERS WERE JUST TRYING TO
COMBINE TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED -- WE FIND A LOT OF TIMES
WHEN PEOPLE THE MENTAL HEALTH
THEY ALSO HAVE A PROBLEMS WITH
ADDICTION.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT WE STREAMLINED THAT.
WITH THIS TASK FORCE TOGETHER SO
THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED.
WITH THAT I DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
I LIKE TO THEY'LL TO FOR TO A
MYSTERY THANK YOU THANK YOU HI
MISTER MEMBERS TOM RENT FREE
AGAIN WITH THE COUNTY BE ABLE
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION --
WITH THE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
ACCORDING TO NATIONAL INSTITUTE
ON DRUG ABUSE HALF OF THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE OF MENTAL ILLNESS
DURING THEIR LIVES WILL ALSO
EXPERIENCE A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND VICE VERSA --
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE UNTREATED
AS WE KNOW CAN LEAD TO MANY
OTHER PROBLEMS CHRONIC HEALTH
PROBLEMS FREQUENT EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS HIGHER RISK FOR
HOMELESSNESS -- UNEMPLOYMENT AND
AND OTHER PROBLEMS.
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT
INTEGRATED TREATMENT PROGRAMS
FOR PEOPLE WITH CO OCCURRING --
SUBSTANCE USE A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS EFFECTIVELY PROMOTE
RECOVERY INTEGRATED TREATMENT
OCCURS WHEN THE SAME CLINICIANS
OR TEAM OF CLINICIANS WORKING IN
ONE SETTING UP A CAN PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE INTERVENTIONS.
IN A COORDINATED MANNER
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA'S DRUG
MEDI CAL AND SPECIALTY MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PROGRAMS REMAIN
BIFURCATED UNDER STATE LAW THIS
STRUCTURE IN WHICH CLIENTS MUST
NAVIGATE TO SYSTEMS AND WORK
WITH DIFFERENT CLINICAL TEAMS.
CREATES ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS
TO INTEGRATED CARING CAN WILL
GET -- NEGATIVELY OUT OF IMPACT
OUTCOMES AS A RESULT OF PARALLEL
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS CARE
PROVIDERS WHO WANT TO PROVIDE
COLOCATED INTEGRATED SERVICES
MUST NAVIGATE SUBSTANTIAL --
SUBSTANTIAL BARRIERS PUT IN
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES ON
DUPLICATED PROCESSES AND RECORD
KEEPING QUIET CARE UNFORTUNATELY
IS TOO OFTEN SHAPE BY
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS OF
EACH DELIVERY SYSTEM RATHER THAN
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL.
IN THIS BILL.
WE'RE CREATING A FORMAL
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS AND AS A
FIRST STEP AND JUST A FIRST STEP
TOWARD IDENTIFYING AND REMOVING
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS.
THAT HINDER THE EXPANSION OF
INTEGRATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE -- AND AND IN DOING SO HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE BETER
CARE -- FOR FOR THOSE WHO NEED
IT OUR IN OUR STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
Q. OTHER WITNESSES AS A OVER
HERE IS FOR THE CLIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I LOVE IT.
YES BUT THIS IS A PORT.
RIGHT NEXT CALIFORNIA THIS
REALLY RIGHT STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALRIGHT -- YES US -- HURTADO AND
THERE'S A GREAT BILL WOULD LOVE
TO JOIN YOU ON A AS A CO AUTHOR.
IF POSSIBLE LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON
BOARD GREAT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR -- THE BILL'S
MOVE BY SIR LEYVA -- SEVERAL SAW
SOMEONE THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S
ADDRESSING IT CERTAINLY A PORT
ISSUE AND BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
TO TRY TO DEVELOP SOLUTIONS
ROUNDED.
INTEGRATING BE ABLE HEALTH --
WHICH LIKE.
THAT'S RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO
THE BILL IS TO PASS A BY THE WAY
I SO YOU ARE ACCEPTING THE
MINUTES.
YES.
RIGHT.
CLASSIFIED AS OKAY SO THE MOTION
IS DO PASSES AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN AYE PAN AYE STONE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROVE HER TADO.
TOTAL I IT LEYVA LEYVA AYE AYE
MITCHELL MONNING RUBIO.
OKAY YOU HAVE FOUR VOTES --
THAT'S WHO WE HAVE HERE RIGHT
NOW WORK FOR THE BILL OF CALLS
WE FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS MUCH.
YEAH SEVENTIES YEAH THAT WAS A
MAYBE WILL DO IS -- THE BILL
START AND GOING THROUGH THE
CALLS ON THE WE WERE WAITING FOR
ONE MORE AUTHORED.
THERE YOU ARE OKAY WELCOME OKAY
WONDERFUL.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO WELCOME SEVERAL
WALDRON [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT MY BILL TODAY.
COUNTY BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
ARE THE EYES AND EARS FOR THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ESTABLISHED TO ADVISE AND ASSIST
SUPERVISORS ON ISSUES IN
PROGRAMS.
WHERE THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY RESEARCH AND MONITOR ON
THEIR OWN?
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS OF THE VOICE OF THE
AS THE COUNTY BILLS MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER I'VE HEARD MANY
INSTANCES WHERE THERE ADVISORY
ROLE HAS BEEN MARGINALIZED.
AND THIS BILL WOULD REVITALIZE
THE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARDS
ADVISORY ROLE TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND CLARIFY BOARD
RESPONSIBILITIES TO HELP IMPROVE
SERVICES PROVIDED.
AND WOULD BRING A BROADER
COMMUNITY IMPACT PERSPECTIVE TO
THE LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARD.
WITHIN THE ADDED BENEFITS OF
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY. FOR AN
INPUT BY THE COMMUNITY.
AND THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO
IMPROVE SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
INDIVIDUALS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESSES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS ON THE NEED
FOR THIS BILL.
TOBY EWING HAS JOINED ME TODAY
HE CURRENTLY SERVES AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
AND ALSO WITH ME TODAY IS
SCIENCE IN STOCK SHE IS
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF A LOCAL
MENTAL HEALTH BOARD.
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU WITNESSES SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DIANE CHEN STOCK
I AM A MEMBER OF THE PLASTER
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH BOARD I
NEED TO CLARIFY I AM NOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD WITH THIS
THAT THESE ARE MY OWN PERSONAL
OPINIONS AND OBSERVATIONS -- I A
HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH MANY
BOARD MEMBERS FROM AROUND THE
STATE AND I HAVE A FEW AGAIN NOT
OFFICIAL BOARD -- OPINIONS BUT
JUST -- FOR AT INDIVIDUAL
OPINIONS VENTURA COUNTY HAS SAID
THEY FELT HISTORICALLY
INEFFECTIVE IN THAT MEMBERS TURN
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
EXPERTS DEFERRING THEIR POWER TO
HIM OR HER.
KERN COUNTY IS IS THAT -- AND
THAT HAVING THE AUTHORITY TO
REPORT DIRECTLY TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WOULD BE IMPORTANT.
SAN FRANCISCO SAYS THAT NO ONE
IS LISTENING TO THE MENTAL
HEALTH BOARD.
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY SAYS THAT
THEY'VE HAD A LOT OF
INTERFERENCE FROM THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATOR'S OFFICE AND THEY
WANT TO CONTROL THE MESSAGE ON
THE AGENDA AND IT WOULD BE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. FOR THE
BOARD SERMON SOLID INDEPENDENCE.
IMPOSTER COUNTY FOLLOWING A
CRIMINAL INDICTMENT OF SEVERAL
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES FALLING AND
THE ABUSE OF SEVERAL INMATES IN
CUSTODY -- THE GRAND JURY
CONDUCTED AN INVESTIGATION OF
THEIR FINDINGS WERE NOT AGREED
UPON BY ALL MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE SHERIFFS AND
HHS DIRECTOR.
SO OUR MENTAL HEALTH BOARD
CONDUCTED A ONE YEAR DEEPER DIVE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TREATMENT
OF MENTALLY ILL AND AT THE AFTER
THE REPORT WAS ADOPTED BY OUR
MENTAL HEALTH BOARD.
COUNTY COUNCIL SO THAT WE IT WAS
INVALID WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO INVESTIGATE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE IN JAIL DESPITE THE
LOOKED STATUTE THAT SAYS WERE TO
INVESTIGATE SPECIAL PROBLEMS --
SO OUR OUR REPORT WAS EVENTUALLY
IT JUST KILLED -- WE HAD AN
ATTORNEY ON OUR BOARDS YASSER
STATUTE THAT SAID THAT WE WERE
NOT ALLOWED TO GO INTO THE JAIL
AND THE NEXT DAY SHE WAS ASKED
TO RESIGN FROM THE BOARD BY --
THE COUNTY EXEC'S OFFICE SO
CONSIDERING THAT THE STATE HAS
REALIGNED SERVICES TO THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND PROVIDING ALL THE
OVERSIGHT IS NOW AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THE BOARDS HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT THEY NEED
TO DO IS TO ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
CAPTION EMITTED CHAIR MEMBERS W.
A. M. THE EXACT ADDRESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVER SEND
KIND OF THE COMMISSION.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO AS YOU'VE
HEARD IS AN INITIATIVE TO
STRENGTHEN THE VOICE OF OUR
LOCAL MENTAL HEALTH BOARDS ON
THESE BOARDS PREDATE THE KNOW
HOW SERVICES ACT BUT THE INTENT
IS CAPTURED IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
THE COMMUNITY GAUGE MEN IS KEY
TO STRENGTHENING OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM AND MANY OF YOU
ARE AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED.
IN TERMS OF HOW FUNDS ARE USED
OR NOT USED.
AND THE BOARDS ARE A MECHANISM
TO ENSURE THAT THE COMMUNITY
DOES HAVE A VOICE IN MINORING
WAS HAPPENING IN SUPPORTING
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
AND THAT THEY ARE ADVISORY TO
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE SEE
THIS AS A LIGHT TOUCH BILL THAT
REINFORCES THE LANGUAGE IN THE
STATUTE CURRENTLY.
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TO WAY
AND TO ADVISE AND GUIDE TO
STRENGTHEN THE COMMUNITY NATURE
OF OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
THOSE REASONS THE COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT WE ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
I THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS ALICE
HAWTHORNE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
CAN ALL THE ON BEHALF OF THE
SIGN BURKE INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
RAIN X. CALIFORNIA'S DISABILITY
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
WIENER WIENER OKAY MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF AND YOUR STAFF FOR THE
CONTINUED CONVERSATION ON THIS
AREA.
OF WE BELIEVE THAT THESE --
BOARDS ARE PARTNERS IN THE WORK
THAT THE COUNTY DIRECTORS DO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS ABOUT STREAMLINING.
AND BEING EFFICIENT WITH THE THE
WAY THAT WE WORK TOGETHER SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE.
UP PLEASE TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATION OKAY THANK YOU.
WIENER **** FOURTEENER OKAY.
MEMBERS FARMING DATING ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES -- I JUST WANNA --
MIRRORED CBH SHE IS COMMENTS AND
AUTHOR HAS BEEN VERY GRACIOUS
AND LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU ANYMORE TWEENER.
OKAY ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NINE QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I YES CENTER OF MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO THANK A LEADER WALDRON
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
MISTER EWING FOR YOUR CONTINUED
WORK.
I THINK YOUR DESCRIPTIVE COMMENT
JUST A MOMENT AGO IS THAT THIS
IS.
KIND OF A A LIGHT TOUCH SHURA A
MODEST REFORM BUT I THINK IT'S
IT'S APPROPRIATE IN HELPING
[inaudible]
EXPAND.
OUR PUBLIC CONVERSATION ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES REMOVING
STIGMA.
AND I THINK BY.
IF IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
ORGANICALLY.
REQUIRING -- THIS INTERACTION
WITH GOVERNING BOARD SPORTS OF
SUPERVISORS OTHERS IT CAN ONLY
RAISE ON THE AGENDA AND
AWARENESS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN THE ONGOING EFFORTS TO FIGHT
STIGMA IMMOBILIZE SERVICES
APPROPRIATELY SO.
WHEN I THANK YOU ALL? FOR THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING IN BE GLAD TO
MOVE THE BILL THE APPROPRIATE
TIME.
I THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OF SO AGAIN -- SEVERAL WALDRON --
MENTALLY THERE ON THANKS SO MUCH
FOR BRING THIS BILL FOR THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BOTH CLARIFIED
THE THE ROLAND SCOPE OF THESE
BOARDS -- AND TO BE SURE THERE'S
THERE'S MORE CLARITY THERE SO
THEY CAN PERFORM THE FUNCTIONS
THAT THEY NEED TO FUNCTION AND
ALSO TO AND THEIR EMPHASIZING
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ROLE AS WELL SO --
WITHOUT -- WHICH LIKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I URGE
AN EYEFUL.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE BILL'S
BEEN MOVED BY CEREMONY THE
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN AYE PAN AYE STONE.
STONE AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW HER TADO FOR TOTO I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL MONNING
MONNING AYE RUBIO.
THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET UP AND
PUT IT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THE FIRST BILL OUT FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
WHAT GRADUATION SPOKE?
ALL RIGHT -- THAT -- WE HAVE --
HAD ALL THE BILL'S PRESENTED SO
WE'RE GONNA START -- JUST GO
FROM THE TOP HERE AND AND THE
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS SO.
WE ARE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
HELLO.
BUT I THINK WE'LL JUST BECAUSE
THERE WERE SO MANY PEOPLE HERE
OKAY SO WHAT LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN.
AS I MENTIONED ITEM NUMBER ONE
WAS PULLED. TO THE CONSENT WILL
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR LATER SO
LET'S BEGIN ITEM NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY ONE SIXTY SIX THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND FOR TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS --
SICKLY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE STONE NO
GROWTH HER TADO.
FURTADO I LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO [inaudible] SIX
OKAY THAT'S CURRENTLY SIX ONE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF AND FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY TWO SIXTY TWO BY
SOMEONE GLORIA SECRETARY AND
MOTIONS TO PASS REFERRED.
APPROPRIATIONS ACT OF THESE CALL
THE ROLL THAT THE NUMBERS DOWN.
STONE I GROWTH HER TADO.
TOTAL I IT LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MITCHELL.
ITEM NUMBER ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY TWO SIXTY TWO BY GLORIA
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES.
MITCHELL IS I MONICA MONNING AYE
RUBIO.
OKAY THAT BILLS CURRENTLY --
SEVEN ZERO WILL -- BUT HAS
ENOUGH OF US TO GET OUT THERE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE EIGHTY
THREE SEVEN SEVEN THE MOTIONS TO
PASS REFERRED ME APPROPRIATIONS
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AYES SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS.
STONE.
STONE IS NOW GROWTH HER TADO FOR
TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING I
RUBIO [inaudible] SIX ONE THE
BILL CURRENTLY IS SIX ONE WILL
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
A SIX AND SEVEN CONSENT WHICH
WILL TAKE AT THE END ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SO -- EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FIVE BUSH'S TO PASS REFERRED ME
IN JUDICIARY CHAIR VOTING ICICLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS DOWN.
STONE I GROWTH HER TADO FOR
TOTAL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS
EIGHT VOTES EIGHT ZERO OF A HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER -- NINE
EIGHTY NINE ONE FOUR BY SUMMER
HOLDEN.
THE CARE VERY I DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS ACT OF THESE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS DOWN.
STONE I GROWTH FOR HER TITLE.
FOR TOTAL AYE LEYVA THEY HAVE A
AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING MONNING HI.
THAT BILL CURLY HAS EIGHT VOTES
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL ON CALL NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY
TEN THIRTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER
NECESSARY IN -- MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING I
SIX OF THESE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I GROWTH.
HER TOTAL HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA
LIVE AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I THAT BURDENS THAT THE
THAT THAT BILL CURLY HAS AT
EIGHT ZERO BUT THE ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- NEXT BILL WAS
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B. TEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBERS
SALAS EMOTIONS TWO PASSES
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE CHAIR VOTING -- A THIS
SIX TO EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS STONE.
STONE I GROW [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING I RUBIO I RUBIO IS I
THAT BILL KILEY HAS EIGHT VOTES --
EIGHT ZERO NEXT THE BILL IS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB -- ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE BY SUMMER GLORIA
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS HER VOTING ICE
EQUITIES CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS STONE.
STONE AYE GROVE FURTADO THE
TOTAL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE MITCHELL MITCHELL
AYE MONNING MONNING AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I HAD A BILL CURRENTLY HAS
EIGHT ZERO WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
NUMBER THIRTEEN IS CONSENT WILL
TAKE -- ITEM NUMBER -- FOURTEEN
YES SO I AND NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
ELEVEN THAT THE SORRY ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY TWO BY SOME NUMBER WALDRON
EMOTIONS TO PASS FOR TO
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS YOU'RE
VOTING ICE ACTIVITIES CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS GROW.
MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO I PAY THE BILLS CURRENTLY
EIGHT ZERO WILL HOLD ON CALL FOR
F. TWO NUMBERS AND FIFTEEN WITH --
WOULD BE HELD. FOR FUTURE
HEARING AND THEN I AM SIXTEENS
ON CONSENT SO LET'S STAND WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
FIVE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR STONE STONE I GROWTH.
FOR TOTO HER TOTAL AYE LEYVA
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
MONNING AYE OKAY CONSENT
CALENDAR CURLY'S EIGHT ZERO ALL
THE CONSENT CAL AND ON CALL --
SO I THINK EVERYONE SHOULD BE
HERE I WILL HOLD CONTINUE HOLD
THE RULES ON CALL FOR A RAINY
MEMBER AND I THINK ALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS I KNOW IT'S BEEN A BUSY
AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
YEAH.
THERE'S A SIX OKAY SO.
YEAH BUT WHAT ABOUT RUBIO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE RUBIO REVIEW BY.
THAT BILLS CURRENTLY SEVEN ONE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL.
NUMBER FOUR OKAY ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWO SIXTY SOUP TWO SIXTY
TWO BY SELLER GLORIA SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT A
GIRL RUBIO.
RUBIO HI.
THAT BILLS CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE FELLOW ON CALL --
NEXT ITEMS I'VE BEEN NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN SIX
THREE PLEASE CALL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE RUBIO.
RUBIO II.
THAT BILLS CURRENTLY SEVEN ONE
WILL LEAD THE BILL ON CALL.
THE REST OF OUR YEAH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RIGHT
.
I I'M I'M SURE THAT EVERY MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE AS AN
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AND
JUST GO AND FOLLOW ORDER FROM
THE TOP
.
RIGHT TO WILL JUST GO DOWN AND
FILE ORDER -- SO -- THE FOR THE
FIRST ITEM IS -- WAS PULLED
SECOND AS A CONSENT WILL DO
THINK IDEA AND SO ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB ONE C. SIX BY SOME
MEMBER GABRIEL -- SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
GROWTH.
GROWTH NO.
THAT BILL IS OUT OF SEVEN TWO
NAMES.
THAT THOSE OUT.
SEVEN TWO OKAY NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY TWO SIXTY SIX
BYE.
BYE A SIMILAR GLORIA THE GROUP
PLEASE CALL THE TWO SIXTY TWO
BUT WE JUST DID ONE DAY DO THAT
WE DID THE NUMBER THREE BY
GIVING.
OKAY SO WE DID LET'S LET'S GO
BACKWARDS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY SIX BY GABRIEL.
THAT WAS AN OKAY NEXT ITEMS I AM
NUMBER FOUR A. B. TWO SIXTY TWO
BY -- GLORIA SORRY.
OKAY TO HOLD OKAY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THAT'S THE NUMBERS GROW
BY.
THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO NEXUS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY.
THE MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GROW.
ROVE IS NOW.
THAT BILL WAS OUT. SEVEN TWO SIX
SEVEN ARE CONSENT WILL TAKE IT
AT THE END.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME OF
HER BLOOM SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS GROWTH
[inaudible]
WROTE HI.
THAT THOSE OUT -- NINE ZERO I
WELL I PROBABLY SHOULD BECAUSE
THE EXACT THE CALL OUT AND AN
OUNCE OF THAT ACTUALLY OF THE
COMMITTEE SO.
THAT'S RIGHT I I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT ITEM THAT NEXT
TIME I AND NUMBER NINE EIGHTY
NINE ONE FOUR BY SOME EVER
HOLDEN SOCRATES CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS GROW.
GROW HI THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
EXAMS I AND